dad dad dad dad dad dr. ready for a  fight evil comes to  oh please I  coming to  hey here comes  I go death death death death this battle  is relentless is there anyone that can  bring peace to Eternia what's going on  over there I must bring peace to Eternia  what in the name of Grayskull is this  who are you I am Ezio Auditore da  Firenze from the price try minion of  Skeletor um no matter you are no match  for the  drills  the greatest battles you've ever  imagined finally come to life command  legendary characters and their armies as  you fight for supreme control over the  toy box toy soldiers war chest Hall of  Fame edition available now